well knowing that your very business
minded do you think back to when you
were 18 and you had offers from those
companies and knowing that you could
have made a very lucrative career
electrician's mate great right and it
would been the safe route in the terms
of maybe not on the job safety sure in
terms of like a steady paycheck
insurance you can sleep at night in
terms of the bills right do you think
back to that day um I think that's a
good question
um you know I I don't know I don't
because I I knew one thing I wanted to
be a professional athlete when I was a
kid and I wanted to be a movie star like
those are the only things that I knew
you know and you know apples oranges
right but like um you know I love doing
electrical work but my parents my
parents wanted me to go to the
vocational school so that I had some
sort of background after high school and
it wasn't just like okay you know
because not a lot of people in my family
went to college so my dad went and later
later after having a family and stuff
one of my uncle's went back to school
and ended up getting his degree one of
my aunts I believe too but you know not
a lot of us not a lot of them had been
you know I think I might have been I
think I might have been the first person
to graduate college from my immediate
family you know including like uncles
and aunts and cousins like believe so um
so you know for them you know we were
coming from more of a working-class
family like you know so having a skill
set after high school was huge you know
what I mean if if you weren't going to
college and so that was sort of more
their decision like yeah they wanted me
to go to vocational school I remember
being pissed and I was like man all my
friends you know I didn't get to go to
the same high school and then you know
you're there for a week and you meet new
people and then you know it's fine you
know you get on with it but um so coming
out of that you know I knew I was
valuable as an electrician but I still
knew that's not what I wanted to do and
I was gonna join the airforce
cuz for me I was like I knew I loved
like the idea of being like a Navy SEAL
or that they're the equivalent of that
to you know the Air Force I think theirs
is called the you know the Army's the
Ranger I figured what the Air Force's
branch of like their specialized unit is
but
like I really want to do that like I
really want to do that you know and then
I was looking at their their sports
program I was like like a plate for the
Air Force I could play for the Navy you
know basketball baseball whatever it was
so you know it was just continuing
process of how can I you know get
towards that my idea of being like a you
know an athlete you know and then they
were the ones my parents were the ones
that didn't want me to join the airforce
and head uncle who several uncles we'd
been in different parts of the military
and my uncle was in the Air Force for
about 21 years or 25 years at that point
and that was before 2000 that was before
September 11th or 9/11 I should say and
when he was like ya know is probably not
the best time during the Air Force you
know and so my parents had this sort of
you know come to Jesus sit-down meeting
with me and we were just like you know
they didn't want me to go and they were
the ones that encouraged they're like
what what about going to Community
College and trying to take some acting
classes you wanted to be an actor and I
was like okay you know and that was kind
of how it happened you know they they
sparked the idea and sort of pushed me
interaction and when we did and you know
here we are
but um yeah I mean I've always been
business minded in that way but I'm
business minded but again like the
passion of me really wanting to do
something that makes me happy as always
what has fueled me since I was a kid so
that always came first
so you know $100,000 at 18 years old or
whatever I could have been you know
making a year like you know now I think
about something while it's love money
right but like maybe it's a 18 year old
I didn't realize how much money you know
I could have been making but no I think
I would have always followed what where
my heart wasn't and it wasn't it wasn't
money it's and and and and that should
still be clear because obviously I'm not
making a lot of it now like you know I
mean I'm not a rich rich act or anything
so you know it's still a very it's it's
still a you know a hustle for sure so
you know I definitely you know I
obviously acting an entertainment can be
lucrative but you know it's a long
process to get to that point so I
probably could still be making a lot
more doing other things that's for sure
if that's where my heart was
you